en el último vídeo hablamos de lo que
son las derivadas parciales de funciones
multi variables verdad es decir que
tuvieran varias entradas y aquí quiero
hablar de lo que son las segundas
derivadas parciales así que vamos a
escribir alguna función multi variable
digamos pensemos en esta función
fx que esto sea el seno de x por ye
cuadrada muy bien esta será nuestra
función multi variable y como vimos en
el vídeo anterior podríamos calcular dos
distintas derivadas parciales verdad
podríamos calcular la derivada con
respecto la derivada de nuestra función
con respecto a la variable x o también
podríamos calcular la derivada de esta
función con respecto a nuestra variable
y en verdad tenemos estas dos opciones
si nosotros queremos calcular la
derivada parcial de f con respecto de x
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es tener
que considerar solo la variable x
a la variable ye la vamos a considerar
como una constante
entonces si derivamos esta expresión con
respecto de x bueno tendremos que
calcular la derivada del seno de x que
es coseno de x por ye cuadrada que en
esencia es una constante para fines de
derivar con respecto de x ahora sí que
si calculamos la derivada parcial de f
con respecto de g en este caso ya será
nuestra variable y x sería constante de
esta forma el seno de x completitos
sería una constante que multiplica a ye
cuadrada entonces al derivar con
respecto de y como esto es constante se
queda igual verdad tendremos seno de x
que multiplica a la derivada de ch
cuadrada que es 2 de verdad
entonces la derivada es 2 y estas son
las primeras derivadas parciales verdad
quisiera antes hablar un poquito de otra
anotación que existe para denotar a las
derivadas parciales y es una anotación
que es bastante cómoda pero
quizás es poco intuitiva y podemos
escribir efe con un sub índice y para
denotar a la derivada de f con respecto
de y lo mismo podríamos hacer para esta
derivada verdad pondríamos efe con un
subíndice xy esto denota la derivada
parcial de f con respecto de x entonces
observemos que las derivadas parciales
son también funciones multivariable es
verdad entonces tiene sentido hablar de
las derivadas parciales de estas
derivadas parciales que ya hemos
obtenido verdad entonces por ejemplo
para esta función nuevamente tenemos dos
opciones para calcular derivadas
parciales verdad podríamos tener la
derivada parcial con respecto de x de
esta función o la derivada parcial con
respecto de ye entonces aquí tendríamos
por ejemplo la derivada parcial con
respecto de x de esta función que ya era
la derivada parcial de f con respecto de
x entonces si nosotros derivamos con
respecto de x a esta expresión aquí está
nuestra variable
que sería cosa de equis esto sería una
constante y entonces al derivar coseno
de x nos queda menos seno de x
multiplicando nuestra constante que es
ye cuadrada verdad entonces lo mismo
podríamos hacer ahora para derivar con
respecto de y nosotros podríamos derivar
ahora con respecto de y esta expresión
que ya era la derivada parcial de f con
respecto a x entonces si nosotros
calculamos esta derivada ahora nuestra
variable sería aquí está esta parte que
es de cuadrada y coseno de x simplemente
es una constante verdad entonces aquí
tendríamos coseno de x por la derivada
de ye cuadrada que es 2 g y ésta sería
nuestra expresión para la segunda
derivada verdad que sería derivar con
respecto de y a la parcial de f con
respecto de xy como en el cálculo
tradicional pues podríamos hacer una
especie de abuso de notación verdad
nosotros podríamos reescribir esto
como la segunda derivada verdad como
podríamos pensar como la segunda
derivada tradicional pero aquí vamos a
hablar de parciales verdad entonces
podríamos poner una segunda derivada de
f y aquí vamos a poner que derivamos con
respecto de x ambas veces verdad que en
realidad podríamos pensar que es con
respecto a x cuadrado aunque aunque esto
es un abuso de notación en realidad es
la segunda derivada de f con respecto de
x ambas veces muy bien y la verdad es
que la primera vez que aprendí de estas
cosas a mí me revolvía mucho digamos que
con la anotación de lightning es verdad
tenemos la intuición de cómo cambia efe
al variar nuestra variable verdad x por
ejemplo pero podemos perder esta
intuición al utilizar esta nueva
anotación al menos al menos podemos
entenderlo digamos como si fuera un
operador de verdad parece al respecto de
equis y lo estamos usando dos veces y de
este lado por ejemplo ahora de este lado
tendremos algo algo chistoso vamos a
tener la parcial la segunda parcial de f
y ahora hay que decir bien cuál es el
orden en el que lo hacemos primero lo
hacemos con respecto de equis y luego
derivamos con respecto de qué bien
entonces así es como se escribe en este
orden
ahora bien podríamos hacer lo mismo con
esta otra función verdad podríamos tener
aquí una derivada parcial con respecto
de x podríamos tomar la derivada parcial
con respecto de x y que es lo que
obtendríamos entonces como siempre
podríamos considerar esta parte que es 2
como una constante y simplemente
derivamos explorar entonces la derivada
del seno de x sería coseno de x por
nuestra constante que es 2 muy bien y
algo genial que podríamos remarcar desde
este momento que al menos a mí siempre
me ha parecido increíble me ha parecido
muy sorprendente es que estos dos
resultados resultan ser iguales verdad
incluso cuando hemos tomado caminos
distintos para llegar a estas derivadas
parciales verdad en realidad nosotros
podríamos
de esta forma que la segunda derivada de
f verdad la parcial la segunda parcial
de f con respecto de x y luego con
respecto de ye que es lo que teníamos de
este lado es este resultado es
exactamente igual a la segunda derivada
de f primero con respecto de ye y luego
con respecto de x que es exactamente lo
que hemos calculado aquí verdad primero
con respecto de ye y luego con respecto
de x y lo que resulta ser sorprendente
es que en realidad esto es válido para
una gran cantidad de funciones de hecho
este resultado es conocido como el
teorema de swartz y dice que si las
segundas derivadas parciales son
continuas en el punto de interés
entonces estas derivadas cruzadas son
iguales y para fines prácticos las
funciones con las que uno se topa
siempre son de este tipo y entonces el
orden de las derivadas en realidad no
importa verdad quizás algo que hay que
mencionar es otra anotación alternativa
con la que podemos trabajar por ejemplo
en esta segunda derivada de f
respecto de x ambas veces podríamos
escribirlo mucho más simple poniendo efe
x x verdad este subíndice que nos dice
xx nos dice que derivamos respecto de x
y luego respecto de x si nosotros
queremos pensar por ejemplo en esta
derivada parcial tendríamos que escribir
efe primero x y luego ye y es que en
realidad aquí hay que invertir el orden
porque aquí lo estamos leyendo de
izquierda a derecha mientras que aquí lo
pensamos de derecha a izquierda verdad
aquí es porque así se lee y aquí es
porque lo estamos pensando como una
especie de multiplicación verdad
entonces está por ejemplo de aquí sería
la derivada primero con respecto de ye y
luego con respecto de x entonces dicho
esto creo que es un muy buen momento
para detener este vídeo nos vemos en la
próxima ocasión